everything with today with what's going  on in the economy I think we have missed  the mark on hero making machine I would  much rather have my guys my kids look up  to a guy like you who's going out there  independently winning making money  becoming somebody that we don't need to  support you he doesn't need to support  your taxpayers don't need to support you  you're taking care of your family you're  educating people we need to clarify who  the real hero is the media is making the  wrong people into Heroes and so for us  it's uh to compete having four kids you  gotta you gotta build a media company  and tell the story the way you feel is  right because uh I think that direction  of turning the right people into Heroes  we've missed the mark the last few years